[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen allen es ist sehr kalt
draußen die deutschen drehen zunehmend
die Heizungen auf die Politik appelliert
an alle weiter zu sparen und feiert
gleichzeitig die Einweihung von
Deutschlands erstem Terminal für
verflüssigtes Erdgas der Kanzler ist
heute vor Ort in Wilhelmshaven an der
Nordsee der Wirtschaftsminister der
Finanzminister auch ein Ampel Ausflug
der besonderen Art denn Deutschland
versucht damit eine Aufholjagd gleich
auf mehreren Ebenen und nach Jahrzehnten
verfehlter Politik solche Terminals
sollen am Ende mal 30% des deutschen
Bedarfs an Erdgas Decken Molly laue
jetzt mit mehr
die höhk Esperanza ist das Schiff der
Hoffnung mit ihm will Deutschland gut
durch den Winter kommen
zur Einweihung sind sie alle da Scholz
Habeck und Lindner wollen zeigen es ist
ein guter Tag um Deutschlands weiteren
Schritt zur Unabhängigkeit vom
russischen Gas zu feiern
das ist hier ein Tag wo man mal einmal
sagen kann wir kriegen das hin wir
schaffen das dann schaffen wir wohl auch
Windkraftanlagen Solaranlagen über
dieses Terminal sollen jährlich rund 6%
des deutschen Gasbedarfs ins Netz
eingespeist werden somit seien auch die
künftigen Winter sicher verspricht der
Kanzler können wir wirklich sagen
Deutschland hat seine Energie Sicherheit
gewährleistet war alle gezeigt haben
wozu wir tatsächlich in der Lage sind
das ist jetzt das neue deutschlandtempo
mit dem wir Infrastruktur voranbringen
und es soll ein Vorbild sein nicht nur
für diese Anlage sondern für viele viele
andere doch es gibt seit Wochen Kritik
am viel gelobten Tempo am schnellen
Ausbau der LNG flüssiggasinfrastruktur
fehlende
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen das
setzen auf eine fossile Energieform
Umweltverbände klagen
nicht stoppen oder verzögern wir wollen
nur dass sich hier an alle Umweltgesetze
gehalten wird die Esperanza das ist
jetzt das Terminal Schiff mit den
niedrigsten Umweltstandards in
Deutschland es ist nämlich das einzige
Schiff bei dem Biozid eingesetzt werden
soll das biozidhaltige Chlor sorgt dafür
dass die Rohre des Schiffes frei bleiben
pro Jahr sollen etwa 35 Tonnen Chlor in
die Nordsee abgelassen werden Anwohner
und Umweltschützer fürchten Schäden für
das Wattenmeer Behörden versichern die
Grenzwerte würden eingehalten
Wilhelmshaven soll jetzt Deutschland
retten mit Energie für das Heizen im
Winter die kalten Temperaturen nagen an
den deutschen gasvorräten
in dem Moment wo die gasspeicherstände
zu tief sinken kann irgendwann einmal
der Moment ausgelöst werden wo die
Bundesregierung über eine gasmangelage
entscheiden muss und es belastet
natürlich die Speicherstände für den
Winter 23 24
damit auch künftig die Speicher geführt
bleiben setzt die Bundesregierung auf
Flüssiggas und weitere Terminals es gehe
schließlich um die Versorgungssicherheit
Deutschlands
eine der größten Industrienationen der
Welt schaut besorgt um ihre
Energiezukunft fast fliehendlich aufs
offene Meer willkommen in Deutschland
hat der Kanzler heute dem Kapitän des
schwimmenden gastherminals gefunkt wir
sind sehr froh ihr Schiff zu sehen
die Sorge von Umweltschützern an der
Küste haben wir gerade schon gehört auf
einer noch mal ganz anderen Ebene
schlagen Sie jetzt Alarm denn die
weltnaturkonferenz in Montreal Kanada
könnte scheitern allein das lässt
aufhorchen scheitern wie kann das sein
vor dem Hintergrund dass 70% der
Ökosysteme der Welt geschädigt sind mehr
als eine Million Arten vom Aussterben
bedroht und damit auch die
wirtschaftliche Zukunft der Menschheit
auf dem Spiel steht aus Kanada Elisa
Miebach
der Schneesturm vor dem Konferenzzentrum
ist nicht das Problem der jungen
Delegierten Julius PAL aus Deutschland
und andere haben lange mit den
Verantwortlichen hier geredet jetzt
protestieren sie Brackets
Klammern das ist das Problem davon gibt
es noch zu viele im abschlusstext der
Konferenz und alles was in Klammern
steht steht noch auf der Kippe an vielen
Stellen im Text sind gerade die Sachen
im Klammern die gut sind die wir möchten
die wichtig sind für die Biodiversität
und für die Zukunft und dass sie noch in
Klammern sind bedeutet dass sie noch in
Frage stehen und dass sie auch eventuell
gelöscht werden können und das wäre
sozusagen das schlimmste was passieren
kann auf dieser Konferenz wird
verhandelt wie das Aussterben der Arten
gestoppt werden kann und damit
Ökosysteme auf der ganzen Welt geschützt
werden können Biodiversität ist die
Existenzgrundlage des Menschen sie sagt
etwa für saubere Luft sauberes Wasser
fruchtbare Böden und Bestäubung von
Pflanzen doch diese Arten und Ökosysteme
sind in einer Krise wir befinden uns
ganz im sechsten Massenaussterben es gab
ja schon einige Massenaussterben auf der
Welt aber dieses Mal ist es
menschengemacht und man kann das man
kann das Spüren also es geht wirklich
die bisasität geht zurück ein Ziel der
Konferenz 30 Prozent der Erde
unterstützt zu stellen besonders die
Gebiete der indigenen Bevölkerung sind
reich an Artenvielfalt und bedroht
alejandra aus Kolumbien erlebt das vor
ihrer Haustür die Rechte der indigenen
zum Schutz dieser Gebiete sollen im
abschlusstext gestärkt werden
es ist sehr wichtig dass den indigenen
Völkern Mittel zur Verfügung gestellt
werden damit sie ihre Arbeit für den
Naturschutz durchführen und auch selbst
leiten können und auch dass sie eine
Entscheidung beteiligt werden und dort
eine Stimme haben
es geht um die unberührte Natur die noch
intakt ist die Industrieländer haben
historisch bereits viel wilde Natur
zerstört die Entwicklungsländer fordern
Unterstützung damit sie ihre Ökosysteme
schützen können anstatt sie nun auch
wirtschaftlich auszubeuten wir haben
eine große Verantwortung und ich bin
deshalb sehr froh dass ich hier mit
einem guten Gepäck in Montreal anreisen
konnte weil die Bundesregierung 1,5
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung stellt für
den globalen Naturschutz ein Schritt von
Deutschland doch ohne feste Zusage wie
das Geld ausgezahlt wird wollen die
Entwicklungsländer auch nicht mehr
Ambitionen beim Naturschutz zustimmen
deshalb ist die Frage der Finanzierung
eigentlich die entscheidende Frage hier
im Augenblick in Montreal um am Ende zu
einem guten Abschluss zu kommen ein
guter Abschluss das hofft auch Julius
noch ist sowohl ein ambitionierteres
Abkommen möglich als auch ein völliges
Schalter
so und Hannah du kümmerst dich auch
heute um den Nachrichtenüberblick und da
schauen wir zuerst in die Ukraine wo es
nach dem massiven Beschuss gestern auch
heute wieder schwere Angriffe durch die
russische Armee gegeben hat wegen der
Zerstörung gibt es viele
ortsstromausfälle der ukrainische
Präsident selenski erklärte bislang
konnte die Versorgung für 6 Millionen
Menschen wiederhergestellt werden zudem
forderte er erneut die Lieferung von
luftabwehrsystemen
wegen Grippe er erst Virus und Corona
sind aktuell an vielen Orten die
Kinderkliniken überlastet laut dem
Deutschen Roten Kreuz mit der Folge dass
das Krankenhauspersonal immer häufiger
bedroht oder sogar angegriffen wird das
sagte der k-präsidentin hasselfeld
gegenüber der Rheinischen Post Eltern
mit kranken Kindern müssten teilweise
stundenlang in den Notaufnahmen sitzen
und kranke Kinder auf den Fluren
übernachten
twitter-chef Elon Muskat eine Kehrtwende
hingelegt und die Sperrung von
Twitter-Accounts mehrerer Journalisten
wieder aufgehoben nach massiver
internationaler Kritik und einer Umfrage
in der auch die User der Plattform für
eine Freischaltung stimmten betroffen
waren unter anderem Journalisten der
Washington Post der New York Times und
von CNN
aufgesägt rausgebrochen eingeschlagen
zimperlich waren die Einbrecher nicht
die vor drei Jahren das weltberühmte
Grüne Gewölbe in Dresden ausräumten und
danach war mehr als fraglich ob wir die
unersetzlichen Schmuckstücke jemals
wiedersehen würden seit heute ist klar
wir werden ein Großteil der Beute ist
wieder da hintergrund ist ein Deal
zwischen der Staatsanwaltschaft und den
Verteidigern von sechs Männern die vor
dem Landgericht auf der Anklagebank
sitzen Stefan Kirch
sächsische Geschichte gefasst den
Diamanten und Gold damals königlicher
prunkschmuck heute Schatz von Weltrang
geraubt vor drei Jahren nun unverhofft
wieder aufgetaucht wir wurden immer
wieder also wir im Sinne von
Staatsanwaltschaft mir als Polizei in
dieser Zeit immer wieder gefragt wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn dass wir
diesen Schatz wiederfinden könnten und
wir haben uns immer betont optimistisch
gezeigt jetzt kann ich Ihnen sagen da
war natürlich ein bisschen Flunkerei mit
dabei natürlich je länger die
Ermittlungen dauerten schmolz auch
unsere Zuversicht und so freudige sie
mir dass wir heute hier stehen können
einiges fehlt immer noch doch 31
Einzelteile sein nun sichergestellt
worden darunter der sogenannte Große
Bruststern des polnischen weißen
adler-ordens das wohl wertvollste Stück
die Hoffnung dass die Kostbarkeiten
nicht bereits zerstört oder einzeln
verkauft wurden hat nie aufgehört
auch keine Hinweise darauf dass Teile
davon irgendwo schon aufgetaucht oder
verkauft waren auch in der Analyse
anderer kunststelle
Vergleich dazu waren wir doch eigentlich
sehr gewiss dass es zu einer Rückkehr
kommen konnte in einer unfassbaren
Aktion zerstören Einbrecher 2019 diese
Vitrine im Dresdner Grünen Gewölbe und
rauben Schmuck im Wert von 113 Millionen
4.300 Diamanten lassen sie mitgehen die
Schatzkammer gilt bis dahin als
einbruchsicher die Sachsen sind entsetzt
derartiges hat es noch nie gegeben
der gestohlene Schatz aus unserem Grünen
Gewölbe hat eine tiefe Wunde bei uns
gerissen und es ist ein Stück Identität
es ist ein Stück sächsische Identität
und wir sind natürlich dankbar wenn
diese Schätze zurückkehren und damit
auch diese schmerzliche Wunde sich
wieder schließen kann
seit Anfang des Jahres sitzen sechs
Tatverdächtige vor Gericht Mitglieder
einer arabischen Großfamilie nun hat
offenbar ein Deal zwischen Verteidigung
Gericht und Staatsanwaltschaft zum
Auffinden der Kostbarkeiten geführt
und jetzt die Lottozahlen die lauten 1
37 42 44 45 Superzahl 3 alle Angaben wie
immer ohne Gewähr
mit einem zwei zu eins gegen marokko hat
sich Kroatien Platz 3 der
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft geholt bereits
in der 7 minute fiel das erste Tor für
die kroatische Nationalmannschaft zwei
Minuten später Freistoß für Marokko und
der Ausgleich der entscheidende Treffer
dann gegen Ende der ersten Hälfte durch
den Kroaten
zu den Wetteraussichten Morgen viel
Sonne vor allem im Süden aber auch Zähne
Nebelfelder am Nachmittag im Westen
wollten -8 bis -1 Grad im Nordwesten bis
plus drei Grad die weiteren Aussichten
unbeständig windig und von Westen her
deutlich milder dabei am Montag in der
Mitte und im Norden große Unwettergefahr
durch Glatteisregen
morgen um diese Zeit ist Party so viel
ist klar wir wissen nur noch nicht ob in
Buenos Aires Rosario und barilochce oder
in Paris Bordeaux und Chamonix
Julio oder Chance Elysee Messi oder
mbappé die Franzosen wollen den Titel
verteidigen für jede und jeden einzelnen
in Argentinien steht so etwas wie das
persönliche Seelen heil auf dem Spiel
Argentinien gegen Frankreich Annegret
Oster gegen Thomas Walde
es ist Hochsommer in Argentinien und
neben der Sonne vom Himmel brennt die
Leidenschaft in den Herzen der
argentinia für ihre Mannschaft und die
wird verkörpert vor allem von einem dem
einen dem Messias es und dir ich bin
ganz aufgeregt wenn ich über Messi
spreche ich bekomme wirklich Gänsehaut
er ist das Größte was es gibt der
Fußball in Argentinien ist seit jeher
mehr als nur Sport er steht für
Selbstbewusstsein Gemeinschaftsgefühl
Nationalstolz alle fiebern sie eine
möglichen Sieg entgegen
wäre so großartig und ein riesiges
Geschenk von den Spielern die sich so
sehr bemühen dem Land Freude zu bringen
in diesem sehr schwierigen Jahr mit
dieser hohen Inflation
im Oktober lag die Inflationsrate in
Argentinien bei 88 Prozent gegenüber dem
Vorjahresmonat viele Argentinier kämpfen
ums wirtschaftliche Überleben
wir sind alle aufgeregt wir wollen dass
es Sonntag ist wir wollen dass es
endlich morgen ist ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand schlafen wird
stattdessen werden sie träumen von einem
Sieg gegen Frankreich und von ihrem
Messias der das schaffen soll
ihr wart toll toll die Bilder nach dem
Halbfinale zeigen die Stimmung vor dem
Endspiel ein Präsident schmeißt sich an
die blauen ran
am Sonntag sind wir wieder da und ihr
Jungs werdet noch einmal gewinnen
sie sind auch wieder da auf den Champs
Elysee in Paris und landesweit heute
beim Spiel um Platz 3 und morgen zum
Endspiel
wir setzen 14.000 Polizisten und John
Damon ein damit die Leute so gut wie
möglich feiern können fiktiv flexible
Paris und andere Städte bleiben bei
ihrem WM Boykott wegen der
Menschenrechtssituation in Katar keine
Fans ohne keine öffentliche Übertragung
doch manche stimmt die Leistung der
eigenen Mannschaft um jetzt da doch alle
gucken möge der bessere gewinnen und ich
hoffe das wird Frankreich sein das
Frankreich im Finale ist das erwärmt uns
und Wärme ums Herz können die Franzosen
in der kalten Vorweihnachtszeit gut
gebrauchen
so wer feiert tiefster Winter oder
Hochsommer morgen wissen wir mehr heute
journal time 21 Uhr 45 bis dann und wir
wünschen Ihnen jetzt
[Musik]